.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
>> YOU BET.
>> Martha: MORE NEWS ON THAT.
LET'S GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE BRIEFING ROOM WHERE PETER
DOOCY IS ASKING A QUESTION.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHAT SPECIFICALLY IS THE
PRESIDENT DOING ABOUT THIS?
>> SO WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE
DAY THE OVERDOSE AWARENESS DAY
THAT WE ARE OBSERVING TODAY.
I JUST LAID OUT WHAT THE SECOND
GENTLEMAN AND OTHERS ARE DOING
WITHIN THIS ADMINISTRATION.
AND YOU KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE STEPS
THAT WE'RE TAKING, THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN.
YOU HAVE THE $80 MILLION THAT
DHS JUST ANNOUNCED TODAY ON DRUG
PREVENTION AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
TAKEN MANY STEPS, HE'S MADE THIS
A PRIORITY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ATTACK A VERY DANGEROUS DRUG,
SERIOUS DRUGS IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> BUT 300 OVERDOSE AS DAY NOW.
WE KNOW HOW THE FENTANYL IS
COMING IN.
IT'S COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BARREDER.
THE DEA ADMINISTRATOR SAYS SO.
SO WHEN IS THE PRESIDENT GOING
TO DO SOMETHING --
>> SO I WILL SAY THAT YOU HAVE
SEEN A 200% INCREASE IN FENTANYL
SEIZURES, WHICH MEANS THAT WE
ARE DOING THE JOB OF CATCHING
DRUG TRAFFICKERS.
200% INCREASE --
>> Martha: AMERICANS LIFE
EXPECTANCIES ARE GOING DOWN AT A
RATE NOT SEEN IN A CENTURY AND
PART OF THAT IS BEING DRIVEN BY
DRUG OVERDOSES.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT GOING TO
DO TO STOP IT?
>> WE AGREE.
WE SEE THE SAME NUMBERS AS WELL.
THE FACT THAT WE'RE SECURING THE
BORDER, THE FACT THAT WE'RE
SECURING RECORD LEVELS OF
FUNDING FROM DHS SO THEY CAN
STOP ELICIT DRUGS FROM ENTERING
INTO THE COUNTRY, THE FACT THAT
IT'S NOT THAT JUST DRUG
TRAFFICKERS THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH AS WELL.
WE'RE STOPPING FINANCE --
>> IT'S NOT BEING STOPPED.
300 -- THIS IS BEING DESIGNED TO
TARGET CHILDREN.
DRUG CARTELS IN MEXICO WANT TO
KILL AMERICAN KIDS.
WHAT IS THIS PRESIDENT DOING ANT
IT?
>> I HEAR YOU.
I JUST LAID OUT 200% OF INCREASE
OF DRUG FENTANYL SEIZURES.
THAT IS A DANGEROUS DRUG THAT
WE'RE TAKING OFF THE STREET.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS, THIS IS AN IMPORTANT AND
IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
I JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THEY'RE
JUST -- THE BORDER, RIGHT?
HOW THE BORDER -- WHATEVER YOU
JUST STARTED.
I JUST WANT TO CLEAR THIS UP.
>> PEOPLE COMING IN, FENTANYL
COMING IN.
PEOPLE DYING.
>> HOLD ON.
MIGRANTS ATTEMPT TO ENTER THE
COUNTRY LEGALLY ARE TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY BY BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
THAT'S THE PROCESS THAT WE'RE
TAKING.
THEY ARE EXPELLED BY THE COURT
ORDER UNDER TITLE 42,
TRANSFERRED TO ICE CUSTODY OR
MONITORED THROUGH ALTERNATIVES
AS THEY AWAIT FURTHER
PROCESSING.
WE HAVE MADE 3,000 ARRESTS IN
THE FIRST THREE MONTHS OF
LAUNCHING AN AGGRESSIVE CAMPAIGN
TO COMBAT THE MULTIBILLION
DOLLAR HUMAN SMUGGLING INDUSTRY.
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH DRUGS OVERDOSE,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
PRESIDENT CARES ABOUT.
PRESIDENT HAS LAID OUT A PLAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS, OUR
BABIES, OUR YOUNG AMERICANS HERE
IN THIS COUNTRY ARE NOT
CONTINUING TO SUFFER FROM THAT
OR NOT CONTINUING TO BE GIVEN
ACCESS TO DRUGS, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO THIS PRESIDENT.
SO TO SAY WE'RE NOT DOING
ENOUGH, PETER, IS JUST FALSELY
CATEGORICALLY WRONG ESPECIALLY
ON THE DAY THAT WE ARE OBSERVING
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND, AND
WE HAVE ANNOUNCED, DHS HAS
ANNOUNCED $80 MILLION TO PREVENT
THAT.
WE'RE DOING THE WORK.
PETER, IF -- LOOK, IF
REPUBLICANS WANT TO HELP US STOP
OVERDOSE AND STOP OUR KIDS
GETTING OVERDOSED BECAUSE OF
THESE DANGEROUS DRUGS, BECAUSE
OF THESE FENTANYL THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE STREETS, WE'RE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM.
BUT THEY'RE NOT.